Subway Joe called Marine Daniel Penny
speaking out for the first time since
his arrest and trying to clear his name
the Avalanche of left-wing smears keep
coming though like this one from
Reverend Al
right A Good Samaritan helped those in
trouble they don't choke them out what
happened to Jordan was a crime when they
choked Jordan they put their arms around
all of us all of us have the right to
live but the 24 year old vet says his
critics got it all wrong quote this had
nothing to do with race he says I judge
a person based on their character I'm
not a white supremacist
Penny also says he'd step up again to
defend others and adds this quote I'm
deeply saddened by the loss of life it's
tragic what happened to him hopefully we
can change the system that so
desperately failed us Penny's lawyer
telling Martha McCallum that he was only
trying to protect others
absurd to say that uh
Danny Penny you know thought he had the
right to take anyone else's life and
intended to take anyone's life this was
a situation where my client who was just
you know an everyday New Yorker was put
in a a situation that none of us would
want to be in and you know took
reasonable steps to try to you know
subdue someone who had introduced a you
know frightening threatening environment
judge could you imagine how much better
things would be if Al Sharpton weren't
just race-baiting like he is but that's
what he does that's what he's always
done and the sad part about it is that
you know there are people who actually
listen to him and and you know you want
to know where Al Sharpton was where the
family was you know when Jordan Neely
needed them and and I was thinking about
this and and the whole thought that this
guy's arrested 42 44 times I'm sure many
more contacts with law enforcement and
he's on a list of the most mentally ill
dangerous people in need of help so he's
out just no one's helping him family's
not helping families lawyers definitely
not helping him Al Sharpton wasn't there
for him but we put illegals in the
Roosevelt Hotel
and we have Americans that we know are
in desperate need of help so much so
that we put them on a list of the top
50. and we just leave them out there
ultimately to die he didn't get any help
at all he didn't get anything that he
deserved but I want to say one thing
about Daniel Penny I was very impressed
that he came out and he said what he
said you know we didn't have to do that
this is a guy you know there's a lot of
passion around this case and you know
the issue of race the more you know
about Daniel Penny the more you realize
you know this guy was is not a guy who's
concerned at all about race that he's a
guy who is very inclusive he always has
been and everything about his life
attest to that but there were there were
other people on that in that train car I
believe in African-American holding down
Jordan Neely but I I think it was smart
for him to do the interview I think at
this point enough you've come across as
a very regular guy 24 years old back
from the Marines where he was a sergeant
give him credit for that and he's in
college studying to be an architect and
you know he's a Long Island kid who just
grew up and you know did what he said he
would do again and that's that's a
strong character yeah do you think he'll
ever get his reputation back I
absolutely do because he's he's speaking
very clearly about what's in his heart
and I think there's a lot of people out
there who can relate to him in the same
way that I do that we're part of a
generation of people who saw the attacks
on 9 11 and were inspired to step up and
commit to Serve and Protect and for
those like Penny who have this protector
mindset it's not something you just toss
aside maybe when you take the uniform
off it's something that's a part of who
you are so of course if he see somebody
who is you know in danger or senses that
there's a threat he's going to put
himself out there without any care for
his own well-being to try to help to try
to Serve and Protect and you know I
think one of the the most negative
things to come out of this both with
what's happening to him but what message
does this send to people if someone is
in need of your help they're going to
think twice like gosh am I going to get
sued am I going to get prosecuted am I
going to get arrested for just stepping
up and trying to help somebody who's
being hurt yeah the Subways are not
going to get more peaceful after this
and the media and people like Al
Sharpton Dana force people to deny that
they're white supremacists and that's
the point they want you to say I'm not a
white supremacist so I think his
instincts might have been to not say
anything well he would have wanted to
say something his lawyers might not have
wanted him to say something but there is
a battle of public relations narratives
that were out there and I think it was
important that he say something before
the grand jury comes back and then we'll
take it from there it's interesting that
Al Sharpton says that Jordan Neely was
just is just like us make actually no
sir because you're you weren't arrested
42 times
and you weren't homeless and you didn't
have all of these problems so no you
weren't just like him and they're trying
so hard to make this a thing and it's
not working partly because the people
who are on the subway who actually have
to use it to get back and forth to work
they know that these things are just so
Random the violence is random just over
the weekend you had somebody who was cut
in the face on the chin with somebody
deranged that came onto a subway car
that guy ended up going to the hospital
is thankfully going to be fine then
there was a woman who was slammed into
the train
um it was already there and it was
stopped but slammed into it again random
by a homeless person so there's no one
out there protesting on their behalf
like where do you go to get that sort of
support so all of this stuff walks right
up to the line before someone says I
better put this person in a choke hold
the other thing I'd say is the test the
interesting thing is the testimony we
have from others that are in the car are
that I did feel like my life was
threatened I was grateful for him to
coming in and I imagine that that will
all be presented at the Grand Jury and
that he will be able to get his
reputation back but it's going to take a
while it will and but they can exploit
it on the front end and on the back end
because if he's not into editor I mean
if he's found not guilty then they can
protest and go crazy in fundraise no I
was told that Al Sharpton had changed
that he had evolved right because we all
grew up oh I've heard people here go
like oh you know he's a friend of
so-and-so's he does these shows you know
if you're young you don't remember uh
how he in the Tawana Brawley case
essentially ruined how many people's
lives who were falsely accused of raping
her in Central Park and then you have
Crown Heights Freddy's Fashion Mart all
these were initiated by a race baiting
and calling people racist whites and
Jews Sharpton has never helped a person
in trouble he's only helped himself
after the trouble has begun right he's
never like it's like you said he wasn't
there for Jordan Neely but he's there
for the family just the way the family
is I think a great question
to ask is why did why did Daniel Penny
have to bring this up to begin with it's
and we predicted this we did say that
the race will be injected in this and I
always want I I said this before
activists should ask themselves would a
black Marine have stepped in to subdue a
mentally deranged felon who is
threatening others if you say no you're
racist because you would assume a black
Marine would do exactly what the White
Marine did and if you don't believe that
you're the freaking racist so
okay I wonder Brian kill Mead I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now